house oversight committee chairman James
Comer joins us now with more
um
[Applause]
time
that when they were going after to
impeach Donald Trump over a phone call
where he basically is saying I expect
you to be more responsible with taxpayer
money Etc okay we had that tape of Joe
Biden then we played it we now we had
the interview with Hunter Biden nobody
paid attention how would you describe
Joe Biden leveraging a billion dollars
to get a prosecutor in Ukraine fired and
and his son continues to get paid
um how would you describe that what
words would you use what adjectives
it's unimaginable I can't think of a
worse thing that a president in history
has done this is a president who has a
history of using foreign aid and
leveraging for for his family's benefit
look at that form 1023 Sean it showed it
dated back to 2017 it said that the
oligarch paid Joe Biden a bribe of five
million dollars he called Joe Biden the
big guy and he said that the
investigators would have an impossible
job of ever tracking that money down
because they were going to launder it
through various different banks and
shell companies that's exactly what
we've proven on the house oversight
committee and then you have the tape
that you just played from from 2017
where Joe Biden admitted to leveraging
foreign aid tax dollars to the FBI knew
this all along yet they never
investigated this one time thankfully
now the house oversight committee is all
right let me stay focused on the first
and incident then we're going to bring
it up to where you are in your
investigation okay Joe Biden leverages
the billion he gets a prosecutor fired
used our money to do it and his son
continues to get paid his son had no
experience he's getting paid a lot of
money and and my question is is that a
vice president of the United States of
America taking specific actions for the
financial benefit of his family because
that's what it seems like to me
otherwise why would any vice president
give a rip about a prosecutor in Ukraine
they wouldn't care about it would they
what
I I think it is Sean and you you look
back why did Joe Biden volunteer during
the end of the Obama Administration to
to fly around and hand out foreign
foreign aid checks and to talk about
foreign policy uh look we we track down
the money in Romania less than two weeks
after Joe Biden left Romania in Air
Force two his family started getting
wires through shell companies that were
laundered back down to bidens less than
two weeks after he left Romania for four
and eight so everything we found in
Romania is consistent with what this FBI
1023 form alleges that the FBI had okay
now and you estimate that nine Biden
family members were beneficiaries
including grandchildren would be in
frontal money through these show
corporations fake llc's
um let me ask you about that you say
between 20 and 30 million dollars from
foreign Nationals is that true and what
do we know about the 17 tapes do we have
them do you know who has them
well with the with the money first of
all we've already tracked down a little
over 10 million dollars we're pretty
confident from other sources that that
number will grow to Beyond 20 million
and it could be more if you factor in
the president's brother who dealt mainly
in the Middle East we haven't even
gotten to him yet uh with respect to the
tapes look it mentioned in the FBI form
that the oligarch had 17 tapes of Biden
two with Joe Biden except in the bride
that he used that as an interest this is
a high-ranking was a high-ranking member
uh or owner of barisma
yes that is exactly right so have you
had anything could you show them
unfortunately nobody's had any contact
with him for the last three years you
know the the MSNBC makes fun of me when
I said that there are a lot of people
that were involved in the Biden
shenanigans that that are are currently
missing but with respect to this
oligarch we think we know where he is uh
he just hasn't been seen in public in a
long time but we're following the money
we we've subpoenaed bank records last
week that are coming in as we speak that
we're hopeful that will show some more
signs of of some influence peddling in
countries including Ukraine this is what
the Biden family has done and they've
never been investigated seriously until
the house oversight committee uh became
a republican majority and we received a
gavel in January I believe the tape of
Joe Biden we played and the tape of
Hunter proves that that was influenced
peddling I think that in and of itself
Congressman Palmer thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else